there are probably thousands of people
watching this right now and this may be
a little egotistical of me but I think I
know what every single one of us
thinking why is he making a video
instead of a shower on vacation guys
having a hotel room with Canford and
this like kind of lock him whether
somebody around I can't really do it but
I don't I don't mean that I mean like
making videos I can't make videos when
there's other people in the room
and there are several other things that
I can't do all the people in remember
that that's what I'm talking about right
now so I've decided to put myself in the
only enclosed space that I can find
which happens to be the bathroom and
make the video so now you know the
question is where am I
well right now I'm in New Hampshire but
very recently I was in Washington DC
ah it's wet in here we're talking around
seeing friends and family know
nerdfighter events I'm very sorry though
it would have been really great to see
some nerdfighters on this trip really I
wouldn't amazing but unfortunately I'm
not do it because obviously I don't have
a lot of free time we're gonna be able
to shower during my time in Washington
DC I decided to go to the zoo it was
actually Catherine's idea the day with a
lot of very loud children you've gotten
your first book what else do you want to
do I wanna see your puppy sized elephant
what about a real sized elephant yeah
I like zoos because I liked your ass he
loved your ass but of all the things
that they have at the National Zoo in
Washington DC they don't have your ass
so that was a little disappointing but
it sees our other animals loving members
of their own species so they were
gorillas living gorillas are they
adorable they're ducks loving ducks but
for all the animals that we stole their
many many many amazing and I was that we
didn't see mostly what we saw were these
really interesting monkeys
I saw all kind of animals when I was at
the zoo tiny deer leopard tortoise hippo
and true an armadillo curled up in a
ball and a nerdfighter bird and it is
nearly all from every corner of the
world from Australia to France but
mostly we just saw monkeys with pants Oh
monkeys with bands monkeys with pants
all we are is monkeys with pants
elephant Falcon I'll say hoot octopi
panda seals and the Mongoose every
corner of the world from Australia to
France but mostly we just saw monkeys
with pants Oh monkeys with pants monkeys
with pants all we are is monkey with
pants look at this I'm looking without
pants surprisingly the songs right
because I wouldn't have the line all we
are is monkeys with pants in there and
all I can think of oh so yeah I should
do all my songs in the shower very
strange I don't think like Katherine I
know she can hear me out there but
because there's a door it's as if I am
all alone and there's no little universe
that I can totally do things like these
with birds and no one will ever know
except for all the people who are
watching this right now
that's kind of embarrassing Oh monkeys
with burns on John I would love to see
you soon and I hope that I do
nerdfighters keep on nerd fighting all
we are is monkeys with bats
monkeys with pants all we are is monkeys
waist pants like a Slurpee